Cho xem ông bạn đến với kênh tin học nó
bảo Nam vào lúc video ngày hôm nay đâu
Bảo Nam vào lúc sẽ chia sẻ với bạn cách
bôi đen văn bản ngang trong Word
giả sử ở trên màn hình đâu bà Nam blog
có một đoạn văn bản bây giờ mình sẽ chia
sẻ với bạn 3 cách để bôi đen văn bản
ngang trong Word
Cách thứ nhất Bôi đen ngang trong Word
cho một dòng cách ngày thường áp dụng
khi bạn muốn Bôi đen một dòng nào đó cha
nhốt
Bạn chỉ cần đưa chuột ra mép ngoài của
dòng cần bôi đen khi con trỏ chuột
chuyển sang thành mỗi tên nghiêng như
bạn nhìn thấy trên màn hình thì bạn chỉ
cần giữ chuột trái như vậy bạn đã màu
đen nhanh một giống bất kỳ ví dụ bây giờ
mình sẽ Bôi đen xanh dòng thứ Hai
thi Bạn chỉ cần đưa chuột ra phần đầu
của dòng sau đó click chuột trái tương
dự ở dòng dưới này cũng vậy Bạn chỉ cần
đưa chuột ra mép ngoài của dòng đó khi
chưa Ừ mình mỗi tên bạn chỉ cần cắt trái
như vậy bạn đã mua đen nhanh một dòng
bất kỳ
tiếp theo mình sẽ chuyển sang Cách thứ
hai Bôi đen nhanh một hoặc nhiều đoạn
văn bản bất kỳ
ví dụ trong đoạn văn bản dưới đây bây
giờ mình muốn Bôi đen ngang đoạn đầu
tiên cho đến rút ban chấm như thế này
thi các bước bạn thấy như sau
bữa thứ nhất bạn đặt dấu nháy chuột vào
vị trí đầu của đoạn văn cần modem sau đó
bạn nhấn phím shift trên bàn phím
và birdlife bạn Kích chuột vào vị trí
cuối của cái phần văn bản muốn Model và
Nhã phí ship như vậy bạn đã có đen một
đoạn văn bản bất kỳ
ví dụ bây giờ mình muốn Bôi đen một đoạn
văn bản từ cái dòng chữ Tuy nhiên thì
bạn chỉ cần đặt giống như chuột vào cái
áo đen Sau đó nhấn phím ship sau đó bạn
đưa dấu nháy chuột vào phần cuối của văn
bản cần mô đen Ví dụ như câu văn này như
vậy bạn đã mua đen nhanh một đoạn văn
bản bất kỳ
em và cái thứ ba bạn Bôi đen một vài từ
ngắn trong văn bản
cách này thường áp dụng khi bạn muốn Bôi
đen một hoặc một vài từ ngắn dừng ở đây
mình muốn Bôi đen Cái dòng chữ Đỗ và Nam
vào lúc thì bạn chỉ cần Click vào giữa
trái sau đó di chuyển chuột để bôi đen
văn bản và nhà cứ trái như vậy làm xong
và cuối cùng mình sẽ sang cách bôi đen
nhanh thứ tư Đó là mô đen nhanh toàn bộ
nội dung của file word
cách này bạn nhấn tổ hợp phím là
controller cậu a trên bàn phím
ví dụ bây giờ mình sẽ nhấn tổ hợp phím
Control + A thì bạn thấy toàn bộ nội
dung của file đã được Bôi đen Cái này
thường áp dụng di bằng muốn mua đem tất
cả nội dung của file Word
và như vậy Xem nội dung video mà rồi đâu
có mọi người chia sẻ với bạn 4 cách bôi
đen ngang trong Word tùy theo từng
trường hợp bạn có thể chọn cho mình một
cách bôi đen phù hợp Cảm ơn bạn đã theo
dõi video Xin chào và hẹn gặp lại bạn ở
các video tiếp theo
nếu bạn thấy video của mình hay và hữu
ích Bạn hãy nhấp chuột vào nay và chia
sẻ video để ủng hộ đó bà Nam với Đông
thai Nếu bạn chưa đăng ký Kênh Đỗ bà Nam
lúc bạn anh chắc chuột vào nút đăng ký
và chọn hình chuông
nhấp vào tất cả để đăng ký và nhận thêm
các video hữu ích từ đỗ bà Nam và Úc Xin
cảm ơn các bạn
Ngoài ra bạn phải tìm kiếm trên Google
với từ khóa Đỗ bà Nam với
và truy cập vào website đô Bảo Nam
plus.com
hoặc kênh YouTube nếu bà Năm blocks để
xem thêm các video cũng như thủ thuật
máy tính tay callosum brother về cách sử
dụng các phần mềm như Word Excel
PowerPoint vân vân và bạn có thể truy
cập Website là đỗ bàn ăn mặt đất chúng
con để cập nhật những bài viết thôi mới
nhất
Cảm ơn bạn đã theo dõi video Xin chào và
hẹn gặp may bạn ở các video tiếp theo